peut dormir tant plu
[Musique]
chemin
ils vont y va se dit champion du monde
des hypnotiseurs vérité ou mystification
à vous de juger ces personnages
insolites qui étaient réunies au premier
festival des records fantastique être
chaman c'est à la fois être fakir yogi
visionnaire télépathe hypnotiseur
prêtres et médecins guérisseur des corps
et des âmes mais c'est également et
c'est moins connu être avant tout un
artiste un créateur sculpteurs musiciens
chanteurs surtout un poète ici quel
record essayez vous tenter
mon acceptation de ce festival en fait
c'est de tenter non pas sur une personne
sur plusieurs personnes de maintenir ces
volontaires qui ont été sélectionnés
sous contrôle médical pendant nos passes
en 29 heures mais 168 heures on peut
isoler le subconscient d'un go x
d'individus 12 en l'occurrence et le
maintien insiste philippe noz nuit et
jour sous contrôle médical pendant une
semaine
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête d'un
nouveau sujet pendant alors justement
pour que ça se passe bien je les ai
envoyées en voyage et il y en a
plusieurs qui sont au brésil qui vient
qui sur la lune y en a un qui est à
bangkok
par exemple si je vous demande de tenter
l'expérience sur laurent qui est un
fidèle téléspectateur d'un sur cinq est
très sceptique quant à ces choses là et
il adore les voyages aussi est ce que
vous allez pouvoir l'envoyer très loin
comme ça je l'enverrai ou chapeau et
nori c'est à dire que le problème dans
l'hypnose c'est qu'on ne peut pas en
dormir n'importe qui il ya des bons et
des mauvais sujet
je souhaite pour laurent qu'il soit un
bon sujet dès l'instant qu'il est bon
sujet je l'envoie où il veut et où que
ce soit il y sera il pourra vous le
raconter après tu t'endors de plus en
plus tu t'endors tellement que ça
5 des mains se détache automatiquement
l'une de l'autre sens la moins convaincu
rigoureuse pour lourdement de chaque
côté de ton corps est aussitôt t'endors
calmement 3 3 je te projettes au pays du
fantastique je te pose est précisément
et pourquoi pas
au royaume des records fantastique et là
tu vois les choses et puis
extraordinaire qui se passe réellement
et pour une fois la réalité dépasse le
rêve dépasse la fiction
[Musique]
e